hey guys welcome to our workflow video
this is our most requested behind the
scenes video on our second channel in
this video we're going to tell you
everything from how we start a video
all the way to literally exporting it to
youtube the way we come up with ideas
you know it's a different process for
every person personally what we'll do is
we'll think of maybe an effect that we
like or we'll think of some sort of
concept that uh might be fun to play
with for example what if there was an
alien on your head yeah sometimes it's
as simple as just having an inside joke
that we find funny and we're like all
right let's let's make this real yeah
unless you have an idea you want to kind
of set up a little bit of a plot
generally speaking a short video story
follows a simple pattern you have normal
life for your character you have a
problem that's created and that problem
is solved one really important thing is
when you're coming up with the concept
for a piece don't forget
what the ending is going to be very
often we come up with an idea for video
and we even start shooting and we don't
even know how it's going to end and then
we sit there on set go oh crap
you really should have planned out this
editing because honestly it's it's the
part of the piece that ties everything
together and it resonates the most with
enemy everyone the next step that you
want to do is write it down simply
writing it down once you get the flow
out and try to write it as if you're
actually watching it some people like to
make storyboards we prefer shot lists
yeah when you're working with a small
group of people
it's just a shot list is completely
sufficient as long as you know all the
moments
that you need to see in order to make
the piece work just try to always focus
on having whatever you're shooting
whatever you're putting in front of the
camera always have it progress things
always have things moving forward each
shot is like a sentence in a story yeah
so once the concept has come together
and you have what you want to do on
paper you start breaking it down into
the parts you need to get to make the
piece we call that pre-production
essentially we go through pick out
people costumes props locations
separating it into all its pieces and
going out and individually taking care
of each and every one so once you have
all your stuff gathered and your camera
is prepared your people are scheduled
your team's going to show up and you're
going to make the video you have now
entered production
and in productions where you actually
execute the piece most of you guys are
probably just working with your friends
and you're doing things for free always
bring food people will show up for free
if they know there is pizza and pizza is
an inexpensive way to pay your crew when
we're in production we like to work
through our piece chronologically but
there are times when you actually need
to jump around chronologically in the
piece for shots that make sense
basically it's good to take the shot
list storyboard however you've planned
out your piece and look at the
assortment of things you have to do that
day and try and group them into the most
efficient way possible if you know
you're going to have the camera in one
place and you need to get a lot of
moments and angles from one certain
position get there run through it all
and then move on because it takes a lot
of time to move people to one spot and
then move them back so you basically
just want to keep people moving as
little as possible between each shot or
setup so we here as corridor digital
actually have a little bit of a team now
to help us do this kind of stuff our
friend jake watson is basically our
producer he's the guy who will help us
organize the props costumes people and
all the stuff we need to make a shoot
happen aka producer for the production
now one really important thing to
remember is
sometimes things don't go as planned on
set and you have to make changes on the
fly that's completely normal it never
goes 100 as planned also when you're in
production make sure you keep track of
your memory cards your batteries and all
the other kind of resources you will
need for your camera to make sure the
day goes smoothly so you have all your
memory cards and you've got all the
footage on it and you want to make this
video this is where we enter
the editing phase and um there's a lot
of definitions for what people consider
editing but this is what editing
actually is editing is taking your
footage
and chopping it up and playing it in the
sequence the in sequence sandwich
editing see
this is hard editing is no more than
taking your footage chopping it up in in
order and putting that into a sequence
that's all it is just getting it there
to watch now when you're editing you're
not going to add vfx here you're not
going to add color or sound or any of
that kind of stuff you don't want to do
vfx too early on because sometimes the
length of the clips change and that just
can create a big pain for you later
where you have to re-time things and do
you don't even know which shot you're
going to use yeah i mean what the heck
you find that this shot's out of focus
this shot's better etc and you work your
cut down until you have your final edit
still no sound still no effects you
might be putting you know temp sound in
there just in case it's hard to imagine
you're gonna be wanting to get uh
feedback on your work um every step of
the way because other people's opinions
and ideas and thoughts
usually help improve the piece so after
you finish shooting your piece you have
all your raw footage you're going to put
it on your computer pay attention to
what you're doing with the footage you
want to keep it organized and you want
to keep your structure clean so you
create a project folder inside that
project folder you're going to have your
edits you're going to have your music
your sound your vfx files you'll also
have a folder for your footage you can
call it footage you can call whatever
you want just keep it understandable and
put all your footage in there your
editing program will need to know where
the footage is when you start working
with it if it's on your desktop or
sitting on your main hard drive in like
some random folder you're going to lose
it and things are gonna get messy visual
effects alright
so you got your edit you know which
shots are gonna have vfx instead of
exporting your entire sequence you're
going to go shot by shot and only pick
the shots that have vfx you're going to
send those to the program something like
premiere it's automated you can simply
select your shot right click and say
replace with after effects composition
it's really sweet we use the feature all
the time it's awesome but other programs
it's not entirely that simple what you
can do is you can open after effects
import that raw footage file
and you'll set the endpoint in the out
point of that file to match the endpoint
and out point of the file in your edit
basically you want to keep your shots in
the highest quality format possible you
do not want to lose quality having to go
back and forth between these programs
that's silly lose all that quality when
you have to upload it to youtube silly
so as i said earlier there's a lot of
different programs out there and there's
a lot of different ways you can go about
editing your footage but over the years
we've really tried to perfect our system
and i think we have something that works
really fast and really efficient
so we work with in all adobe um we use
adobe premiere for editing we use after
effects for most of our compositing and
visual effects
now when you're editing in premiere you
don't have to do any transcoding you can
pretty much work with any raw file
format that's out there so that makes
that very simple it helps to also have a
faster computer with a good gpu when we
start vfx we like to split up the work
based off of our specializations i tend
to do a lot more like motion graphics
heavy work um so when it comes to bright
lasers and stuff i i do that um nico has
been uh doing a lot more 3d work than i
have so when it comes to you know
lighting and rendering a scene making
sure that's all like
locked in and good he handles that for
me i also handle uh some other
specialized 3d stuff as far as like
doing like liquid simulations and like
object tracking and little things like
that and so when we combine them all
together we have a
really really good uh vfx workflow uh
from start to finish also quick pro tip
for you guys if you know that you're
gonna be doing motion tracking or
stabilization to your footage shoot at a
higher shutter speed to eliminate motion
blur i'd recommend at one over 120 or
higher
so after i've done my effects i need to
export the clip in the highest quality
format i can but something like
uncompressed is way too big and doesn't
even play back in real time
so there's basically two codecs out
there that work for this if you're on a
mac you can use prores it's super high
quality but it still plays back and you
can actually edit with it on your
computer if you're on pc you can use
something called dnxhd which is made by
avid this one's cross-platform first
you'll need quicktime which is free and
you simply do a google search for dnxhd
and you can download that codec and what
this basically is it's a super high
quality codec that will not eliminate
any data from your image so you'll
preserve all that crisp high quality
awesome work you've been doing in your
effects program and you'll bring it back
into your edit so you'll pick your
export settings you pick quicktime
you'll pick avid dnxhd as your video
format and then there's this little
window that pops up that has all these
crazy options here's what you need to
know first off
709 and rgb levels the two different
kinds of color spaces that the codec can
use
just pick the rgb levels button ignore
709 then there's some stuff for alpha
alpha means transparency so if you are
trying to export a video with
transparency to be layered over another
video in the future that's what that's
for for the most part you can just
ignore that just be aware of what you're
shooting shooting in your resolution
and your frame rate but then you also
see the data rate you'll see one that
says 115 175 35 etc basically that
refers to the quality 175
is the max 115 is around the middle and
then like 35 is really low
finally you're going to see something
called bit depth or color depth this is
where things can get kind of weird
because for the most part the vast
majority of you guys out there are
working with 8-bit footage what this
means
is that your footage only has 256 values
of red 256 values of green and 256
values of blue to define the color of
your footage
now better cameras and i'm talking like
ten thousand dollars plus can shoot in
ten bits or more where you actually have
a thousand values of red a thousand
values of green and a thousand values of
blue what this means is as you start
color correcting and you start pulling
certain colors out and muting other
colors you'll have a crisper cleaner
image with less artifacting and less
banding and all other sorts of weird
issues that you'll get from footage so
10-bit footage is the best if you have
it for most of you 8-bit will be fine
but just be aware that it exists now
that we have all the vfx shots done what
we do is we take them all and we bring
them right back into the edit and
complete our locked cut of the edit
everything is there everything is final
and we are not going to be making any
more changes this is the point at which
we start splitting off into various
areas such as sound design since we have
all the vfx in there we know
what sounds we have to match up to the
footage
music since everything's timed and
everything is kind of you know put
together we have a good idea for how the
piece flows and also
we can move on to color grading uh niko
usually handles the initial round of
color grading while i shift my focus to
doing sound design or music once you
have your vfx completely done your edit
is completely locked there's literally
nothing else going into your head
now it's time to color grade what's up
what's up
i can't wait to see potion so first
things first we're going to take your
timeline and you're going to flatten it
rather than having clips all over the
place going to try to flatten everything
down to one video track it'll make color
grading easier we use davinci light it's
actually free you can get it off the
blackmagic website and we'll do another
piece talking about color grading more
in depth but basically at this point i
go through
and i correct any color mistakes i
correct any exposure mistakes and then i
stylize the footage from here i'll
export our master file which is once
again a dnxhd file which has both the
video and the sound
and then from that master file i'll make
any other exports i need to make such as
h.264 exports for youtube so you're
doing your final h.264 settings for
youtube there's a couple of specific
settings you'll want to pick
first off your bit rate is important you
have the option options between vbr and
cbr variable bit rate or constant bit
rate constant bit rate gives you the
most consistent performance so the size
is a little bit bigger we recommend at
least 8 000 kilobits per second or
higher we actually export most of our
pieces at 13 megabits per second aka 13
000 kilobits per second audio can
basically be encoded into an mp4 format
which is also referred to as aac it's
very similar to mp3 128 kilobits per
second or higher it's totally fine for
your good audio so i hope you guys
learned something from this that's what
i say at the end of every video but i
really mean it it's a really really
really important thing to uh get a
bearing on because if you're going to be
doing a lot of projects it's something
you're going to want to nail down and
just become very efficient with you're
going to get good fortune
good health good relationships
everything you get even more good
fortune and good health and good
relationships if you follow us on
twitter
on facebook too if you wish we post
different types of things on twitter and
facebook let's talk about the workflow
of twitter
but until then have fun making videos
good luck
you